hola
China under she no doubt stable and
strong but the price is paid for by
people surveillance and censorship crack
down and control this weekend he could
be made leader for life this part has a
new air of permanence
so this is your this is your father
that matters hugely to people like a
buddakil she's a Muslim uighur these are
her family members arrested and
disappeared
in her home province of xinjiang over a
million have been reportedly detained in
camps an entire culture quashed she's
now alone on the other side of the world
haunted by the last time she heard from
her family
Xi Jinping is very likely to be given
another term and given everything that's
happened to your family how does that
make you feel
foreign
ERS are involuntary re-education but
many see this as the most extreme
example of she's China where descent is
now almost impossible
any protest here is increasingly rare
this one last week was remarkable but an
army of Senses rapidly removed any trace
of these images
people know they are monitored the
result is fear and self-censorship
marjian's books have been banned in
China for years he took part in the
famous Tiananmen protests that he said
would be impossible now
if anyone says one word about Hong Kong
Tibet xinjiang on WeChat or the pages of
a manuscript they will be disappeared or
put in prison or silenced so there is a
huge fear now that envelops society and
this is the plan this is what Xi Jinping
had in mind when he took control
she will close the Communist party's
Congress this weekend his rule almost
certainly extended his China is
challenging the world but challenging
him is now harder than ever Helena Smith
Sky News in Beijing